hey everybody I am I'm recently
unemployed and so I signed up with a
temp agency and much to my dismay they
actually called me yesterday and said
that they have a job for me starting on
Monday and it's been a couple years
since I worked in an office so I thought
I should probably do something to
prepare to get back into all the typing
and filing and phone-answering and
whatnot so what I did was I had a friend
of mine go with me down to the local
swimming pool and I had him tie me up in
a burlap sack and sink me to the bottom
of the pool and then just as I was about
to suffocate he hanged me up and gave me
a lunch break I am the last time that
actually worked in an office was kind of
horrific because I had to do a lot of
filing and one time my boss had me file
every day all day for two weeks straight
and finally at the end of that two weeks
it occurred to me I'd probably be better
off if I just went ahead and joined a
cult because at least in a cult when
they sucked the life force I to you they
thrown some group sex in a weird haircut
that's good times
I have an idea of how I could make a
living without actually having to work I
think that I'm gonna try my hand at
being a motivational speaker just hear
me out
I I don't know if you all know who Tony
Robbins is but he's kind of a personal
hero of mine because he's figured out
how to make a living by sharing his life
skills with people and charging a fee
and I think that I could probably do the
same thing so this summer for the first
time ever I'm offering my encounters
with depression power weekend and we're
gonna have several seminars including
potato chips Friend or Foe going outside
and other tales of courage and then the
last one for the weekend is called
sleeping it off it's never too early to
go back to bed so you can sign up for
that on the way out
I am I always wanted to know what it
feels like to be one of those really
super organized people so last weekend I
cleaned my whole apartment and I put all
my stuff in boxes and that felt kind of
interesting so then I went and got a
label maker and I put labels on each of
the boxes according to what was inside
and so now I just have a box of razor
blades that says Plan B on it
[Applause]
I am I grew up in Los Angeles and I had
some kind of weird times when I lived
out there the weirdest one being when
this complete stranger asked me out on a
date at a stoplight I used to drive an
old Volkswagen bug and so at first he
was just talking to me about my car and
I thought that's probably harmless but I
was really relieved when the light
changed and I sped away but then he
caught up to me at the next light and he
started talking at me again and
eventually he goes hey do you live
around here and I said no I don't I live
very far away and he goes well why don't
you give me your phone number and we
could go out for coffee sometime and I
was like yeah okay or you know what how
about I'll just meet you naked at a
shallow grave and you can push me in
that's what you're about buddy and then
a thanks a lot you guys think
[Applause]